the history object contains the URLs
visited by the user within a browser
window the history object is part of the
window object and is accessed through
the window history property if you see
here we have an alert with history that
length the window is just implied this
could easily be window dot history dot
length so if I run that and it's going
to say 3 that means there are three
items in my history if I just put back
here we can see there's two here plus
the current one that I'm on and we can
also do history dot back and this is
just a method just like clicking the
back key on your browser
okay I'm gonna save this and then I'm
going to run that it's going to show me
the number of pages and then it goes
back to the previous page now this can
be tricky here so I can hit forward here
to go back to the previous page but
since I'm on code pen it automatically
runs this again so I can't really change
this and one hit OK it's going to go
back again so now we're kind of in an
infinite loop or stuck so we can't
actually get back to that page that to
load it because it's automatically
running this history that back well
there is kind of a work around here
so after this question mark I can just
type in turn off J s equals true now I'm
going to copy this whole thing and
because when I press ENTER here it's
still going to go back because it was
already just about to do that now I'm
going to paste in the website with the
turn off J equals true and now it's not
going to run the JavaScript
automatically so I can do a make this
into a comment I can save this I can run
that and now it's it's not going to oh I
have to actually remove turn off J
equals troops I can't run it while
that's on and so I'm going to go to this
press ENTER to go to the website again
and now it's going to show four but it's
not going to go back they've that
commented out so another thing you
instead of having back here you could
put forward and another thing you can do
is this
history dot go and if I put a number in
here like three any any number here you
it will go back that many times into the
history so now it's going to go back
three pages into the history or if you
have it a positive number it's going to
go forward pages into the history or if
you have a zero it's just going to
refresh the current page but I'm not
going to demonstrate that because then
we'll have the same problem with the
JavaScript automatically running but
another thing I want to show you is
replace state ok replace state takes
three parameters first I'll talk about
the last one the last parameter is going
to change the actual domain name up here
so it's going to instead of saying l YJ
lgd it's going to say unicycle dot HTML
the second parameter is not actually
used by the browser it's for possibly in
the future and maybe javascript will use
this but it just sets a name to that the
page and then this is a state object
that you can pass in that you can then
access the state later this can be any
JSON object basically I'm just using a
string but it can be a JSON object and
this is going to basically replace this
entry in the history so right now in the
history it's going to have this website
up here in the address bar replace state
is going to replace this history entry
with this new history entry so the
previous history entry won't even be
there it won't even show this website
it's going to show this website in in
the history now there's a weird thing
with code pen where if this doesn't
actually work correctly but if I'm going
to if I copy this I'm going to open up
the JavaScript developer console by
doing option command J
it's different on windows and then I'm
just going to run this command here and
if I press ENTER you'll see right up
here it changed its now unicycle dot
HTML and if I run this you can see it's
four which will it was at four before so
we haven't changed the number of pages
in the history and now if we do console
dot log history dot state and I'm going
to run that it's going to pop up four
and in the console says Bo is great that
comes from this state here so you can
access this first parameter that you
pass in by just going to history state
now that's just a way to save some
information between pages and when you
go to different pages you can access the
same information now another thing to
point out is that this website up here
doesn't actually exist there is no code
panda io / spoke on slash bin slash
unicycle HTML so it didn't actually load
that page when you call replace state it
does not actually load the page it just
changes it in your address bar up here
you can put a full URL here as long as
it has the same root URL that you were
already on I'm just going to copy this
and bring it into my console and we have
an error so let's see what happened oh I
should not have had the S for some
reason I'm not on the secure version of
code pen so it has to be the exact same
beginning of the URL to work so let's
try that again so now you can look up
here code panda io / Bo is awesome so we
can replace everything after the main
domain name but if you put something
wrong in the main domain name you get
this error that we had up here and if I
run this again you will see it's still
going to have the number 4 here and when
we ran that is going to
an error here because of a weird thing
with code pen but I want to show you
another one more thing history dot push
state now the first two parameters are
optional push state and replace they are
almost exactly the same so the first
parameter is the state the second
parameter is the name that's not used
and the third parameter is what the
domain name is going to be so we'll put
this into free code camp so I'm going to
copy this and I'm going to spring over
to the JavaScript console that's just
cuz of code pen here and if I run that
now you'll see it scope into IO slash
free code camp and if I run this it says
five up here remember before it kept
saying for now it's saying five and
replaced it we replace the current
history entry with a new history entry
push date just adds a history entry so
it's still going to have the page you
are on in the history and now it's going
to have a new page in the history so if
I press the back button you'll see
there's this an extra item here before
we just had this first code ten history
now we've the second coachmen history
right there well that's the history
object thanks for watching
my name is Bo Carnes don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good